Speaker 1: All right. The presidential campaign
of Ron DeSantis, who is governor of Florida, is
predicated on the idea that Florida is great and
that he will make America like Florida. There are
all sorts of articles and discussions about this.
Chancey de Vega wrote a piece, Our friend Chauncey
in Salon called Ron DeSantis wants to, quote, Make
America Florida. That's a dire threat. The Trump
DeSantis race is a boon for the mainstream media.
For the rest of us, it's an unmitigated disaster.
And indeed, it is true. If the United States
became like Florida, it would be a disaster now.
Oh, my goodness. Hold on. Wait, hold on, David.
You go to Florida all the time. How can you go
and say it would be bad for the entire country to
be like Florida? Florida is so bad. Why are you
going to Florida? I go to Florida. Right. With the
income I earn from my New York. Business and with
the security of my New York health insurance,
knowing that I and my family have our New York
doctors and New York infrastructure and access to
New York airports, I go to Florida to go to the
beach for a week. This is not an endorsement of
making the country like Florida. There are places
in South Carolina I've been to that are nice.
But that doesn't mean South Carolina needs to
be the model for the United States. And when you
look at Florida, you see, okay, it's 25th out of
50 on health care in terms of quality, access
and cost. It's not a disaster, but it's not a
model to be followed. When you look at health
care in New York, Connecticut, Massachusetts,
etc.. Florida is 20th in infrastructure. All
right. It's not nearly the worst. But why
would we say that's the infrastructure model we
want to follow? Florida is 33rd in opportunity,
26th on crime. These aren't great numbers.
They're very mediocre numbers. They're not
great and they're not terrible. But it doesn't
make us say the whole country should be doing what
Florida is doing. Florida also has something that
artificially makes it better in the rankings than
it otherwise would be, which is it has the benefit
of money earned in other states, blue states,
people from California and from Washington and
from Illinois and from New York, Connecticut,
Massachusetts, who say, hey, I'm going to go to
Florida for the weather or I'm going to retire
in Florida. And so Florida is the beneficiary of
productivity and income and money that comes from
other states. If every state were like Florida,
all of a sudden you lose that benefit. You look at
COVID. DeSantis was quite reckless when it comes
to the COVID pandemic, and he didn't institute any
meaningful public health measures. He, in many
cases, flouted them. And as a result, Florida's
COVID death rate, we're talking per capita now is
the 10th highest in the country. DeSantis has been
a staunch opponent of environmental protection
and climate action and renewable energy. If you
spread that to all 50 states, it's a disaster. So
the bottom line is that if the Santos was able to
do to the country what has happened in Florida,
it would be very bad for the environment and it
would be very bad for our move towards renewable
energy. DeSantis has been a fierce advocate of
voter suppression and gerrymandering. Many states
have made great strides in those areas. If the
Santos had his way, all of that gets reversed.
He's signed bills that restrict voting rights,
limiting mail in ballots, drop boxes, early voting
hours. He would try to do that in every state.
A vocal opponent of civil rights, human rights
and women's rights, he signed bills that banned
trans athletes from participating in school
sports, limiting abortion access, preventing
local governments from passing anti-discrimination
ordinances. This is all an unmitigated disaster.
So Florida can have nice beaches and restaurants
and primarily the liberal areas of Florida, if
we're totally honest. Although Pensacola is cool.
Okay, I will admit that this state can still be
something that we would want to avoid the entire
country becoming. And that is the only promise
that DeSantis is making. It's where Wolk goes
to die and whatever else. By the way, speaking
of woke, we're going to talk about what's going on
with Chick fil A, which relates to Florida in some
significant ways. That'll be a little bit later
on in the show. If you believe that making the
country like Florida would be a good thing. Please
contact me info at David Packman dot com with the
data. Skip the rhetoric, skip the insults, skip
the ad hominem. Skip the. But David, you went to
the beach in Miami. Give me the data that tells
us why making the country like Florida would be
a good thing. Make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel, of course, at YouTube.com slash
the David Pacman show. Back right after this short
break. The David Pacman Show is a program that is
very different than, for example, The Daily Wire.
This came up in our discussion yesterday about the
comments made by Cuban-American streamer Stephen
Kenneth Destiny Bernal, the second. The Daily
Wire has all these major millionaire potentially
billionaire donors. But I want to be conservative,
certainly millionaire donors who just say, hey,
take money, do what you can, grow as fast as you
can. We don't have that. We actually depend on
people like you who say, Hey, I'm going to get
a membership for six bucks a month or I'll pay
for the entire year, and that will drop it to the
equivalent of five bucks a month. Or I'll use a
coupon code like 24 starts now and then it'll only
be three bucks a month. So I do want to encourage
you, if you value what we're doing and if you
understand the ways in which the right is so much
better positioned in terms of the media ecosystem
than the left, consider getting a membership at
join Pacman dot com. You'll also get the benefit
of access to the bonus show. Yesterday, producer
Pat told the story of blacking out from heatstroke
on Sunday at a half marathon. Waking up in an ice
bath and ultimately being brought by ambulance to
the hospital. An insane story and dozens of
you. Dozens and dozens of people commenting
with similar experiences. Shockingly. And anyway,
a sad event that is quickly going down as one of
the most popular bonus shows in history. Sadly,
because it was a horrible thing that happened to
Pat. The bonus show is available every day to our
members. You can sign up at join Packman dot com